thank you Yasser we are indeed with the
2021 U.S open Champion Alex Leonard Alex
welcome back to St Louis we did analyze
your game with Levon but tell us what
you saw from your perspective in this
game
yeah
um well um so as you could see with the
opening choice I sort of went for a
pretty interesting fight like I played a
nice Solani usually when you play nice
Salon it's like going to be a three
result game so obviously I feel very bad
that the game ended the way it did like
that was certainly not my intention to
do it like that because
um you know I
the you know it's
like I I don't I don't remember the last
time I had a a game like this where I
had to make a draw uh where I ended up
making a drawback repetition as early as
like before move 20.
um how did you make that decision
to stop the game at that point and go
Knight F3 and I yeah so if we go back to
Bishop C2 Knight A5 so but when when I
played so first of all um if we go back
to the position after 1283.
um it's if I remember correctly Lavon
had a game with black
um after Bishop takes C3 he did against
Peralta yes B Tech C3 Rook C8 and he won
that game and it's a fight
um and I think I had an improvement
there so I was gonna hopefully try to
play that position
um so you have this position in your
preparation this morning yes excellent
um but he surprised you with this one
he's surprised with the should we sell
and now I believe I had that in my notes
and I believe I analyzed this but the
thing is the position is so unusual
there are like many setups for black
it's just like one of these positions
that's hard to completely analyze till
the end but I still thought I had a
reasonable enough knowledge and that's a
career relatively rare line that I
thought maybe Levon wouldn't be quite as
familiar with
um I mean I don't remember if Bishop C2
exactly was in my notes but I thought
it's a pretty logical move and then here
he played Knight A5 and I don't really
recall on this exact position in my
notes but result 95 is the most logical
move but then I saw he can play Knight
C6 and I was like okay at the worst case
scenario I can play Knight F3 and you
know then look for something better
later on not not necessarily make a
drawer just yet but at least see what he
does maybe he'll want to play for a win
also because certainly black I didn't
think black absolutely had to play
Knight A5 I thought he can also consider
taking a risk and there's only some yeah
playing other moves
exactly and it's not clear that they're
like you know that much worse for black
or anything like that so so I thought
okay 985 95 seemed like the most logical
move and I played it relatively quickly
maybe about five minutes and then he
played Knight C6 quite quickly so I
thought well I wasn't sure if it's
preparation or not during the game I
thought like maybe he's he just thinks
it's the most logical move but I thought
it's possible it's preparation but I
wasn't sure so here I really had a
pretty deep think I tried to see if I
can I think originally I wanted to play
something like Bishop E3 maybe but then
I just didn't like it so much I thought
Rook C8 and I didn't really see what my
next move is
um I also considered if we go back
instead of Bishop E3 I consider taking
and then ideas like Queen D3 or rookie 3
but in none of the positions I thought
I'm better I thought if anyone was
better it's black because you got a
chance to exchange a pair of minor
pieces in iqp and normally that's
something that favors the side playing
against iqp so I thought well and at
this point I was also burning time so I
thought at this point I'm playing a
slightly worse position unclear position
maybe my opponent is in prep and I have
to make I'm the one who has to make
tough decisions and I'm not even sure
what move I'm supposed to play so it's
like you know whether I have a drawing
hand or not I'll be be thinking about
this position a lot anyway so at this
point I'm falling behind the clock 10 20
minutes and you know so I decided to
play uh Knight F3 definitely feels like
and practical decision yeah and then so
I repeated once right and then he and
then I thought well also it wouldn't be
uh okay so he repeated one Knight F3
Knight A5 right
um yeah yeah and then here of course I
thought well what other options I had in
this position I thought maybe bishop G5
I thought maybe bishop F4 but yeah none
of the lines I really liked all that
much and again I was already 20 minutes
behind on the clock so I thought well
okay I have to make a move because at
this point what if he decides like if I
can't go down like
like an hour on the clock because if you
go 95 96 then he can go Rook C8 yeah
exactly or not Rook C8 right away
exactly so I can't be irresponsible and
fall behind too much in the clock so I
have to make a move relatively quickly
so I okay I played 95 and I was hoping
maybe I'll give myself one last attempt
to really go deep and try to find
something there like if maybe a
something opens up a miracle happens but
you know then you know if we go back to
96 yeah so here I was considering all
sorts of ideas right again Knight C6 I
was trying to calculate queen of three
you know I was I was trying to look at
all sir queen of three you can put it on
the board but I thought Rook C8 you know
or queen C8 maybe which is the best move
in the position yeah actually it seems
like black is starting to take over yeah
and like every trial was looking at like
at the best I thought the position is
unclear and keep in mind there's a
Chance season prep and he's ahead on the
clock so I thought okay at this point it
would just be irresponsible for me to
actually play the game game on because
yeah at this point I'm just playing
clearly in not equal terms I'm pretty
sure at this point against any GM I'll
just make a draw here because it's uh
yeah it's just one of these positions
where it's clear that I have to take a
pretty big risk if I want to play on so
I mean I feel very bad I feel very sorry
for the fans that they had to see a game
like that but yeah at this point I
thought of just
you know would be very irresponsible for
me to keep playing the game it's a long
event and I do believe that this was the
practical decision Alex will see you in
the next games thank you
thank you indeed Alex a big surprise for